what would it take to build a more
perfect world
with Nations at peace
a healthier planet for our children
and prosperity for all
what knowledge will we need what values
will unite us
who will lead the way
today humanity is faced with challenges
that are growing increasingly serious
and complex
climate change and environmental
degradation
political extremism and War
Economic Development and disparity
migration
and Global health
the hope of a prosperous future will
require commitment passion and planning
a multi-disciplinary approach to problem
solving
a willingness to consider diverse
viewpoints and an abiding belief in our
ability to find answers together with
wisdom facts insight and courage
[Music]
for more than 300 years Yale has
advanced Humanity's understanding of
complex Global issues and educated
leaders committed to addressing them
by establishing the Yale Jackson School
of global Affairs we further underscore
our commitment to cultivate an intimate
community of outstanding faculty
seasoned practitioners and students who
will study and develop policy to address
the challenges of today and the
opportunities of tomorrow to advance
Yale's Mission with outstanding research
and scholarship education and practice
prepare students for leadership and
service on the global stage
Be A Champion for light and Truth in the
world
[Music]
to all of you who have helped make the
Yale Jackson School of global Affairs
possible thank you
and to those who will lead on behalf of
humanity
the future belongs to you
[Music]
thank you